24 teams hundreds of thousands of fans
and no less than five mascots will be in
place for this Asian cup just over a
year has passed since the men's World
Cup kicked off in Qatar the country is
now readying itself to host Asia's
biggest football
tournament Palestine will be making
their third consecutive appearance a
team providing a focal point of
positivity for their Nation it's more
than a game we it's unite everyone unite
the fans unite the players unite the
teams bastan will always be in our heart
and the bastan team will be here I think
he will F he will will find a lot of
support China had been due to Stage this
edition of the tournament but pulled out
in 2022 due to its zero co9 policy as
World Cup hosts in waiting at that time
Qatar was in the perfect position to
step up at short
notice I think that qar uh got the trust
of the International Community in
hosting uh uh Global events and
international events in a sport and I
think nowar is the Hub of all sporting
events happening uh in the world katar
is about to become the first country to
host the Asian Cup on three
occasions Kat's team are entering this
tournament with a point to prove they
are the reigning Champions having won
this trophy in 2019 in the United Arab
Emirates but they failed to rep
replicate that form on the world stage
their 2022 World Cup campaign began with
high expectations it ended with three
straight defeats Qatar did finish 2023
on a high with two Big World Cup
qualifying wins over India and
Afghanistan their effort to retain the
Asian title begins against Lebanon on
January the 12th Andy Richardson Al
jazer
Doha make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer